for our main story tonight we're going
to talk about the internet it's a
magical place where you can find
communities of like-minded individuals
like for instance the tick tocker who
created a charming video of things
narrowly fitting into tight spaces
something that this exceedingly british
woman was a big fan of
here we go
oh that went nice that literally fitted
perfectly oh that's nice
oh bloody hell bit close for comfort
that
stressing me out a bit but that was nice
oh go on
oh yes go on how'd you find that all
these things fit you know what i mean
why'd you just sit in your house and
just think see if things fit in holes
you know what she's asking a legitimate
question there and i do think that the
answer is yes
but sadly our story isn't going to be
about the fun side of the internet
tonight it's going to be about the
rampant misinformation on it it's
something that we've covered multiple
times before from alex jones to vaccine
misinformation to conspiracy theories
but tonight we're going to be looking
specifically at misinformation that
spreads among immigrant diaspora
communities basically instead of stuff
like this facebook post in english
titled the fake vaccination of kamala
harris which incidentally facebook has
flagged as false information we're going
to be looking at stuff like this post in
spanish featuring the exact same video
which as of taping has no such warning
and that actually isn't that surprising
when you consider that according to the
recent facebook files expose a well more
than 90 percent of facebook's monthly
users are outside the us and canada when
it comes to the hours the company spends
on monitoring this information last year
only 13
were spent on content from outside the
us so it seems that facebook's adopted
the same general attitude to
misinformation that the oscars took
toward best pictures for the first 90
years of its existence basically if it
doesn't happen in english it doesn't
fundamentally matter
and the spread of misinformation has
real consequences when a reporter
recently tried to figure out why
vaccination rates among latino
communities in california's central
valley remain low one woman explained
her reluctance like this
come again
[Music]
not great is it and it's a pretty good
reminder of how thanks to social media
it is possible to silo yourself off and
have very different experiences of
living in america because she was aware
of a doctor from el salvador peddling
covert cures but had never
heard of dr fauci and on that point i
honestly kind of envy her whatever you
think about fauci i think we can all
agree it would have been great to have
seen significantly less of him over the
last year and a half that woman will
never know the dystopian hell of seeing
fauci superimposed over a votive candle
or hearing people refer to the vaccine
as a fouchy ouchy she enjoys an inner
peace i will never know and look we
clearly haven't remotely figured out
what to do with english language
misinformation yet as proven by the fact
that when i say the words horse dewormer
or the letter q you know exactly what
i'm referring to but i know it is hard
to imagine that this situation could be
worse when it comes to non-english
language misinformation it honestly is
so tonight let's talk about
misinformation in diaspora communities
how easily it can be spread and what can
be done about it let's start with the
fact that while some misinformation is
basically the same in other languages in
other cases it taps into culturally
specific interests or fears for instance
communities with lived experience under
communist or socialist regimes are often
targeted with misinformation that tries
to stoke fears about socialism in fact
joe biden's underperformance in majority
latino areas in florida may have had a
lot to do with the fact that before the
election cuban communities were
absolutely inundated by false claims
like this for the past few months many
hispanic american voters have seen
reports and images trying to tie joe
biden to socialism for instance this
photo has been floating around on social
media it claims to be jill biden next to
fidel castro but in fact this is false
it's actually a photo of leighton regent
explorer thor heyerdahl and his wife
jacqueline beer
okay that photo is clearly not jill
biden and that is definitely not joe
biden although it looks a lot more like
him than this animatronic version at
disney world's hall of presidents does
what is going on there that looks like
what would happen if an elderly anderson
cooper got a facelift from a plastic
surgeon without a medical license
and sometimes the spread of
misinformation is exacerbated by the
fact that for many diaspora communities
here in the united states there just
aren't many alternatives in their own
languages for many older vietnamese
americans there is such a vacuum of
credible news channels that broadcast in
vietnamese that many turn to youtube for
their news with certain channels on in
their houses 24 7. one popular host
based here in the united states is nui
vu who brands himself king radio he's
basically a vietnamese alex jones as you
can see in rants like these
china completely has control of biden
the whole situation with hunter biden's
laptop and the trove of data it contains
i think xi jinping has got his hands on
all of it
george soros was part of the financial
plot to overthrow the trump
administration
why are we still being forced to wear
masks masks are killing people are human
living them if you're in a state that
gives you the right to not wear a mask
and then you enter someone's house but
they try to make you wear one tell them
you you
i mean you can see where the alex jones
comparisons come from both have voices
that sound like bones going through a
wood chipper both have an inability to
control the volume of said voices and
both have set clearly inspired by
windows 95 screensaver also they both
seem to have the same business model
with king radio selling his audience
viagra medications and beauty creams
that he claims are made by his cousin
which should be a huge red flag unless
his cousin is named steve clinique i do
not want any creams from that individual
but again while alex jones has been
removed from youtube for spreading
misinformation king radio is still going
strong on the platform despite the fact
you just heard him say masks are killing
people which clearly violates youtube's
ban on claims that wearing a mask is
dangerous and what i guess this means is
alex jones could probably find his way
back onto youtube if he could just
complete a rosetta stone course in
vietnamese
and as bad as facebook and youtube are
and they are screamingly screamingly bad
at least in theory they can be monitored
but there is another way misinformation
spreads that's actually invisible to
most people and unfortunately also
happens to be one of the most popular
tools of communication among immigrant
communities and that is private
messaging apps the biggest by far is
whatsapp owned by facebook which is
massive all over the world so much so it
has become part of many people's daily
routine in india sending good morning
messages on whatsapp is incredibly
popular meaning millions of people wake
up every day to relatives having sent
them one of these or even a video like
this
[Music]
i will say that is an aggressively
pleasant way to wake up
when we came across that message
uploaded to youtube the top comment on
it was simply nice which
is pretty striking nothing else on that
platform has a response that wholesome
you just know the american version of
good morning would have a top comment
like you know who had a morning
harambe rest in peace king but it's not
just whatsapp certain communities have
their own preferred app korean
immigrants have cacao talk while more
recent chinese immigrants use wechat and
if you are not on these apps it can be
hard to understand just how central they
are to people's lives
this tune and loading screen are
instantly recognizable to over 1 billion
people around the world
in china where most western social media
is banned wechat is essential
people use it to text each other order
food hail rides and pay for things
outside of china the diaspora uses it to
connect with fellow chinese speakers and
issues in the country they're living in
exactly communication food orders travel
payment everything all in one app that
is so much more efficient than the
us-based model where you have one app to
convince you everyone's having a better
time than you one that functions as an
endlessly refreshing fury generator one
for pretending you'll meditate one day
one that lets you pay too much for fast
food one for horny mistakes and one that
simply lets you know that you're very
old and the world no longer belongs to
you so i guess in a way
who knows to wechat for streamlining our
shared digital nightmare into one
convenient place
so these apps are a cheap and ubiquitous
way to allow people to stay in touch
with family and friends and also get
news and share information in their home
languages which is obviously very
appealing unfortunately they're also a
huge vector for misinformation there is
actually saying in the latino community
in the venezuelan and cuban communities
about latia
it's the aunt that goes on whatsapp and
receives
any type of conspiracy theory and
forwards it to all her contacts we all
have somebody in our family like that
oh yeah we do
and it is almost comforting to know that
regardless of background every single
family has one member that when anyone
gets a message from them the first
response is to go ah what now
it is a truly universal experience
and there are particular reasons these
apps have become especially fertile
grounds for misinformation for instance
in many countries facebook which
remember owns whatsapp has partnered
with mobile phone carriers to make
accessing its services a lot cheaper
than accessing the rest of the internet
so misinformation can spread far and
wide without the same ability to check
it in brazil a broadband connection can
cost up to 15
of a household's income essentially
making fact checking too expensive for
the average brazilian which is a truly
terrifying thought and wechat has its
own features that make sourcing harder
to follow because it has a function for
users to set themselves up as what's
known as self media basically a pseudo
news channel but there is a crucial
limitation there while facebook and
twitter generally allow publishers to
post links that take users to other
websites wechat bends most publishers
from embedding hyperlinks in articles
this means pretty much everything is
self-contained on the platform
it's hard to find the original source
material and debunk it
right and that is a big deal because who
your source is matters a book called how
i broke rules and made history reads
completely differently if it was written
by ruth bader ginsburg or osama bin
laden so misinformation can circulate
freely on messaging apps and in closed
groups basically invisible to the
general public and sometimes when the
messages are entered and encrypted even
to the companies that host them and
they're often being passed around by
trusted friends and family members
lending them an aura of legitimacy and
it can be truly exasperating for younger
people to see just how susceptible their
relatives are to this
subreddit's like asian parent stories
are full of posts like wechat up
my parents
and listen to this woman read a message
that was flying around her south african
family's whatsapp group
please do not full petrol to the maximum
limit it may cause explosion this week
five explosion accidents have happened
due to filling petrol to the maximum
please do share this message rescue one
one two two i've never heard of it i've
never seen it so i don't see how she
believes it but you know what because
whatsapp says so
it's true
your car is gonna explode yeah
it's true i mean it's not your car is
not going to explode what is true though
is that misinformation like that is
everywhere on these apps our own staff
has had family members circulate things
like these videos in korean promoting
conspiracy theories like q and on or
this post about how ayurvedic doctors
say we can save ourselves from
coronavirus with tips like boiled black
peppers in water and add lemon juice it
kills the virus which would be great
news if it was true but you know
it isn't
the problem is so familiar to younger
generations that one son of indian
parents mocked it on tick tock like this
here's how you make brown parents
believe literally anything you're gonna
start with the plain background and
write whatever you want but just make
sure you write it in the spawn that's
crucial now mention any religious text
and talk about body mind spirit or
something like that and make sure that
you mention a harvard scientist helped
confirm ancient wisdom because we love
those headlines i make a diagram that
looks scientific and religious at the
same time and throw some sanskrit on
there don't worry about accuracy
beautiful now mention some chemicals i
chose kanye and drake's name and made
them look like compounds it doesn't
matter if they're real or not our uncles
and aunties have phds in science but
that's no match for whatsapp now it's
imperative that you insult western
medicine and culture at this last part
you know the drill three dots three
exclamation points cite your sources and
make the image quality a little worse
and that is perfection
yeah
yep
all it takes
is a few superficial labels and style
choices to convince people that
something with no real substance is
actually meaningful and good or as it's
known in america the marvel cinematic
universe and while that was grow up and
wow and while that was clearly fun that
that guy later posted a follow-up saying
that his image had worked slightly too
well because it was making the rounds on
whatsapp but not always as a joke
and we have seen the very real impacts
that misinformation on these apps can
have in india misinformation has been
linked to violence and deaths to the
point where whatsapp felt it necessary
to create this ad
meet kavya
[Music]
she lives away from her family first
time
[Music]
but very close to their hearts
on the family's whatsapp group but today
she's a little serious fufuaji has
forwarded some random fake news on the
family group kavia called him writer
namaste do you have some proof for that
message or did you just forward it just
received it on some random group and
made him understand that fake news can
cause violence we shouldn't circulate
something dangerous right she convinced
fufaji to leave that group
be like kavya share joy not rumors
yeah yeah
sure it's a nice sentiment but it's also
not great when you have to produce a psa
essentially saying look some of what's
on our service is dangerous nonsense and
if you could help clean it up for us
that'd be really great
at the very least they might want to
change that slogan to share the
responsibility for keeping
misinformation for destroying the fabric
of our society because we clearly can't
do it
so what can we do about all of this well
ideally platforms like facebook youtube
and others would be at least as
proactive about taking down
misinformation in other languages as
they are about taking it down in english
which i know is a low low bar
but it does say something about where
we're at right now as for private
messaging apps that is trickier because
of how they are designed and even when
some have taken steps to slow the spread
of misinformation they've often amounted
to half measures whatsapp for instance
started placing limits on the number of
chats a message can be forwarded to
capping it at up to five chats at a time
which might sound good but in practice
it leaves plenty of room for damage
if a message is sent to a whatsapp group
of 20
then each of them shares it with 20
other people
and
this happens five times
it can reach more than three million
people very quickly
yeah it can still spread pretty far and
i know that this isn't the main point
here but also how many of us are in two
group chats of 20 different people each
and if you are how the do you sleep
how do you get anything done without
constantly swiping away notifications
and if you're thinking well hold on it's
not a problem just mute them then how do
you catch up on anything that's happened
in the chat you're gonna spend half your
day scrolling back up just so you know
what this gif meant in context
mom sent that
in response to what i have to find out
a key problem right now is that many
communities don't have the same
fact-checking resources that
english-speaking ones do if someone
sends you an alex jones clip you can
respond to it with any number of trusted
sources debunking him you can send them
something from politifact or snopes or
factcheck.org but if someone sends you a
clip from king radio vietnamese language
fact-checking sources are thin on the
ground there are some there is viet fact
check a volunteer-led project and the
interpreter which works to translate
news articles from reputable outlets
into vietnamese but these are often
small organizations and the people
running them are outmatched and
understandably exhausted so
groups like these badly need resources
to better match the challenge that they
are facing but beyond that there needs
to be public pressure on platforms to do
something about all forms of
misinformation whether they are in
english or not because a whole lot
depends on this and until they do if you
are a member of one of these diaspora
communities you may need to prepare
yourself for more difficult
conversations with your least favorite
uncles
although there is one tiny way that we
may be able to help you here because we
made some good morning messages
specifically tailored for your needs
like this one which reads good morning
take every chance you get in life and
rethink sharing news from a
source
it might be easier to send that to an
uncle in the morning rather than you
know speak to him or you can even send
him a video message like this
[Music]
that's right it may not be the morning
message that they want but it is
definitely the morning message that they
need
and for vietnamese americans in
particular if any of your relatives have
king radio on in the background 24 hours
a day we made a special message just for
you
[Music]
you can download that message in both
english and vietnamese and a few more
messages like them at
bettermorningmessages.com feel free to
use them when you cannot handle a whole
conversation but no deep down you do
really have to say something that is our
show thank you so much for watching
we're off next week we'll be back after
that good night
you